what's up everyone
welcome to the first of many
stream sessions that we will be doing
of my profound distillations
as you guys know i am a polymath
which means that i have learned much
across many different disciplines and
i synthesize
and i distill
and so in this first of many
of these streams
i'm going to talk about different
subjects
straight from my distilled
notes to help you guys grasp
the true profundity of what it means to
actually sponge up
wisdom from different disciplines and be
able to
integrate that into your perceptual
schemas
that then enable you to maximize your
own gifts and flourishing and the
collective prosperity
this one is very close to many of our
hearts
this is the california water system
i'm very excited because you're going to
see a lot of interesting aspects to the
way that i actually distill
here right off the beginning you can see
that i have
i'm using what's called exegesis
which means to draw out i'm using
colors i'm using formatting like bolding
like all caps i'm using emojis
and in doing so i'm able to
to draw out the profundity okay
you'll see as we go that there are
beautiful visual images for you
as well along the way and that's going
to give you
a deeper
landing an ossification of the knowledge
inside of you
and so we have
this most
artistic style of distillation that is
going to have the highest efficacy
all right so we'll begin some of the
highlights
of the california water system
if california was a separate country
it'd be the sixth
largest economy in the world
you all hear me say that on the program
quite often
california would be the sixth largest
economy in the world
as a state by itself and that has
a lot to do with three major
areas of california silicon valley
hollywood and
the central valley so silicon valley
meaning san francisco
oakland san jose the whole bay area
hollywood meeting the whole los angeles
metro area
and then and that and that very much so
includes
san diego and that's kind of interesting
because it's
called silicon beach right you have
silicon valley and you have silicon
beach
down here in southern california
encompassing
the los angeles and san diego scenes and
now you have silicon hills that's coming
up in austin texas which is very
fascinating
and then you have the central valley and
the central valley is the agricultural
beauty of the almost the entire planet
and we'll unpack why in another
conversation on california agriculture
specifically
in terms of gdp rankings this is
always important to address along the
way
the united states has about a 21
trillion dollar gdp
china has a 14 trillion dollar gdp but
is very quickly
surpassing the united states and things
like purchasing power as well as
overall is projected to absolutely
blow past the united states this century
in gdp japan 5 trillion as the third
germany 4 trillion as the
fourth uk at five with
three trillion and then there's
california in spot number six
at three trillion and then the next
countries in order go france india
brazil sorry france india italy brazil
canada korea russia australia spain
mexico and indonesia
the usa has been the world's largest
economy since 1871
150 straight years
about to be overthrown in the 2020s by
china which is crazy
growing at 10
per year over the last 30 years
and a lot of this has to do with deng
xiaoping's cultural reformation
we're very lucky to have went to china
to collab in 2019
on geopolitical diplomacy mission
the usa is also
second worldwide in natural resource
value at
45 trillion dollars these are us dollar
figures
and second worldwide in manufacturing
after china and
as you guys know we are big advocates
for the code of law
in the united states the united states's
social fabric
is very very keen for entrepreneurship
innovation that's been stimulating
economic growth for a long time
the usd is most widely used currency for
global transactions
all right a little bit of background
now we'll dive in
again as the sixth largest economy in
the world as a state
california by itself water is extremely
important
extremely important that's why it's
sustainable development goal number six
water and clean water and sanitation
that's why it's sdg number six because
it's that paramount you have to have
water at the nutrients in high level
perception
you have to have water at the seed
in the nutrients for it to be able to
blossom fruits
and this very similar with the human the
human seed needs
nutrients water in order for it to be
able to fruit
if there's no water if you can't walk
over to your tap
and turn it on and get water there will
be
massive disruption
people will become primal very fast so
water is a
paramount resource and we must take it
very very very seriously
so the california water system
specifically serves 30 million plus
people
just to give you an idea i come from the
state of south dakota
right my lineage is armenian but i was
born here as a first generation
immigrant in
sioux falls south dakota and the whole
state
of south dakota in the midwest of the us
has less than one million people
the whole state of south dakota has less
than one million people
the california water system serves 30
million plus people
it also irrigates approximately six
million
acres of farmland across seventy
thousand farms forty percent of
california water is
used for agriculture
70 000 farms that means 70 000
farmers that means hundreds of thousands
of
employees that are employed by the
farming industry the egg industry here
in california
almost half of the water is going to be
used by
egg alone okay and now you'll see why
california provides
half of usa's
fruits vegetables and nuts that's a kind
of a
broad way to say it and if you break it
down
a little bit more clearly it's that
california
provides specifically approximately 33
percent of
all of the usa's vegetables
and then it produces approximately
two-thirds or 67 percent
of all of the usa's fruits and nuts
which is crazy one state
produces two-thirds of the united states
fruits and nuts
and one third of the vegetables that is
insanely important because
on that root level with the basic needs
the human needs food like they need
water
and so if something happens to the
california
water supply then
you have a massive problem with the
california agriculture
industry and if you have a problem with
the california egg industry that means
every single person across the united
states
has a severe lack of nutrients for their
seed because they can't go to the
grocery store to get
their vegetables fruits and nuts like
they could
before with such voracious demand
so when we walk into the grocery store
we have to
think we have to feel we have to
understand the interconnectedness of
everything that massive hydrological
cycle that moves on the entire planet
that then
comes into the in california the sierra
nevada
snowfall and that then melts into the
rivers that we then take and use in our
agricultural system to grow our food
california's droughts have been some of
the most
painstaking moments in the history of
united states agriculture and
we need to take this very very very
seriously because we don't
fully realize how hedonically adapted we
are to walking into grocery stores
and just getting whatever we want
whenever we want
and not thinking about the supply chain
and the interconnectedness of all of the
planet and people that bring that
food into the grocery store for us to
buy
california produces 40 percent of all of
usa's organic
production it has the most certified
organic farms in the usa
the central valley is one of the world's
most productive ag regions
so that's at the world level so
california central valley is at the
world
level that's huge that's huge
230 plus crops are grown in california's
central valley
230.
on less than one percent of total
farmland
in the u.s in central valley
it produces eight percent of our
nation's egg
output by value 45 billion
so on which is this is nuts
on less than one percent right this is
the pareto this is the power law
distribution
on less than one percent of all of the
farmland in the central valley
it's producing eight percent of the
nation's agricultural
output wow
and so you can imagine that that one
percent of land
is extremely valuable it's extremely
fertile it's been the the soil
has been providing us with
the capacity to blossom
the fruits the nuts the vegetables that
we want
and we need to think long term like the
indigenous
seventh generation principle around
what's gonna happen in one generation or
two generations or three generations or
up to seven
generations down the line if we're
continuously
using the soil repeatedly
in a style of a monoculture where it's
just one
plant or one crop rather than it being
rotated
or rather than it being a complete
permacultural
system we need to really start thinking
in terms of
holism as we do our egg in order to make
sure that we don't have
oops moments with the nutrient densities
of soils
extremely financially lucrative
california farms received
50 billion in cash receipts in 2019
exporting 21 billion
approximately 26 percent of volume of
production
and that's more than 13 percent of the
nation's total egg
value
producing 400 plus agricultural
commodities
california farms it's crazy
more than 13 percent of the nation's
total egg value
wow
and you'll see more of this data
on california agriculture
in one of the next
streams that we do
regarding our distillations so you'll
see california agriculture
and you'll see the
the incredible report that california
makes
every single year that i took the data
from and the images from it's an
incredible report and you can find it
in the california department of
agriculture this
well designed reports great taxpayer
dollars so
look for these reports more often you'll
find really good data distillations
and synthesis that then you can share
with others
and add to your own augmentation of
perception
so now you have some background about
why
the california water system is so
freaking
important because it's literally giving
330 million people in the u.s
a third of their vegetables and
two-thirds of their fruit and two-thirds
of their nuts
of course it's [ __ ] important
so
that's good background now
the idea of an aqueduct
aqueducts are genius they're brilliant
i love them they
they inspire us
to look back at our roots of where we
came from
and how smart we were to realize
that we could use gravity to pull
water to the cities that were located
at sea level so we were populating
cities at sea level
and we needed to bring fresh water from
higher elevations
right like we were talking about the
sierra nevadas and the snowfall
and then the the melting into the
rivers that then go down via gravity
so cities extend aqueducts to mountains
and rivers
and they get fresh water from the
hydrological cycle
and remember it's the same hydrological
cycle that's been
on the planet today as it was 66 million
years ago when dinosaurs were drinking
water
we are still drinking the same water
that dinosaurs drink 66 million years
ago it's always so profound to
immerse ourselves in that again so it's
brought down by gravity
to the city metros near sea level
and these were some of the first places
we had ancient egypt
india greece with archimedes water screw
rome
and then persia persia had the canaan
the oman country and then petra
in jordan which we'll have a photo of
here in a moment
south america as well
and then i'll go ahead and show you some
of them and
come and come back as well this one
i believe is from the california
i'm sorry believe this one's from the
arizona water project
this one here and you can see that i
believe this is the colorado river
okay so you can see how that looks
and then this is the one from petra in
jordan
and you can see that this is where they
would have the
there on the left right underneath of
the tree in between the rocks that's
where they would have the water
the aqueduct and then this is a roman
aqueduct
down here at the bottom and this roman
aqueduct is actually currently located
in france
and if you want to do further research
on these just go ahead and take
a screenshot of them and then upload
them into images.google.com
and you can do further research on any
of the images that you find
interesting it's cool stuff
okay so those are the reals
those reals in the one from petra and
jordan rails are smaller aqueducts used
for consumption or agriculture or
aesthetic
some of the roman aqueducts still supply
water to rome today
reservoirs are large natural slash
artificial lakes
used as source of water supply
reservoirs are an
insane invention as well with dams we'll
get to that in hydroelectrical power
all this type of stuff
microbiomes drastically change when tap
water changes
tap water location changes like me
traveling between california and south
dakota
so it's kind of interesting because
in this case i was drinking the
hedgehechi
water system in here in the bay in the
bay area in northern california now
we're in southern california so our
water source has changed
and then when i went back to home to
sioux falls south dakota to
do the high level perception
distillation
that i was using the lewis and clark
regional water system
so i'm literally drawing water from
ground aquifers in south dakota
which are surrounded in many times
on beds of quartzite rock which is
different than hedgehedge
than hedgehechi here in northern
california
and so we have to remember that
it's even at that level of
interconnectedness where when you fly to
a different place around the world
and you drink different tap water that
you're you're creating a different
microbiotic changes
and that's very interesting all right
aqueducts are genius all right on we go
water in california
all right so california has a state
water project
the acronym is swp
it's one of the world's largest most
productive and most controversial water
systems
and actually it's extremely
controversial with a hetch hetchy
up in northern california and it's also
extremely controversial with down here
in southern california with los angeles
and the uh owens valley which has had a
massive redirection
of water to los angeles so we will
talk about water rights as well in this
stream
this is one of the largest public water
and power utilities in the world
30 million plus people rely on water
carried by these rivers
it irrigates six million plus acres of
farmland
generating six thousand five hundred
gigawatt hours of hydroelectricity per
year
the largest single consumer of power in
california
so net usage is around 5 100 gigawatt
hours
the sacramento river watershed and san
joaquin river basin
the california aqueduct is the main
channel
and you'll kind of see the sacramento
river and the san joaquin
river basin here which i'll i'll kinda
we'll bring this up as we go as well but
you can definitely start seeing that
there's that there's that then
there's that sacramento
in san joaquin
and they're pouring right into that
california aqueduct
and that's going right down to the
central valley
and that's going right to la as well
and that's providing to northern
california as well it's so so beautiful
so we'll get to investigate this a
little bit more
as well
so so nice oh my gosh
and i'm so grateful for we should
definitely be grateful for the
geographic
information surveyors the gis teams
because it's the gis teams that go and
actually map
the rivers in our states and then enable
us to have beautiful data visualizations
like this
all right so there's some interesting
stuff here that
70 percent is used for urban areas and
industry
in southern california and bay area and
30 percent is used for irrigation
in central valley agriculture
to reach socal it is pumped 2882 feet
over mountains
right so this is where in socal
it's a lot harder to pump the water
over mountains whereas in norcal you get
this kind of
very steady gravity that drops it all
the way from
hedgehechi all the way down to
the south bay and then up
and into the bay area in san francisco
so the the edmondson
pumping plant is the highest single
water lift in the world at 1926
feet the california state water project
is estimated annual benefits of 400
billion dollars to the california
economy
it was incepted in 1960
and it has required construction of 29
dams 18 pumping plants
five hydroelectric power plants
700 miles of canals pipelines
and tunnels and it spans two-thirds the
length of california
all for you to be able to go and fill up
some
tap water clean up some dishes
you know take a little shower
use a little dishwasher water some
plants outside
make your coffee like
that's a lot that's a big that's a lot
of foresight
to think so far in advance
to make this state water project so that
30 million
people that rely on it can actually get
water we have to think this way
we have to think with this foresight
it's so important
and to think in an interconnected
seventh generation principle way
the agri business lobbyers helped
skeptical norcal and socal pass the bond
and this is this is pretty funny because
those
as those those many of us know in
california there's some sort of a funny
relationship between norcal and socal
where there's a little bit of
uh this cute like
play there's a play between there's a
dynamical interplay
it's funny some people are so pro socal
and some people are so pro norcal
and i more i i in my perspective
the people that see both of them as
absolutely unbelievably
gorgeous and full of richness
and and beauty and intelligence
are at an even higher level than those
that are just picking
one over the other they're both so
incredible
i miss mount tam so much
i miss china beach those are two of my
kind of favorite spots over in
norcal but i love you too socal i love
you too
so norcal was worried that socal was
stealing their water
norcal was like we have more access to
the sierra nevadas
we don't want socal to steal our water
and socal was worried that other states
using the colorado river
were trying to get la to stop using it
which is funny because you know socal is
taking water from the colorado river
and so the california state water
project
could be unseen as an incentive for la
to stop using the colorado river
this is the water rates this is a lot of
the water right stuff it's crazy so the
bond was passed on an extremely narrow
margin
of 174 000 votes
out of 5.8 million ballots cast
so the bond was passed by such a small
amount
so the oroville dam in the sierra nevada
foothills
that's the tallest dam in the usa it had
the crisis in 2017
after the california rainwater flooding
and this is very interesting because it
was the wettest winter in
almost 100 years
the river water flows more than 40 times
normal speeds at 25 000 cubic feet per
second
and this flood followed the 2011 to 2017
california drought
which from 2011 to 2014
was the driest in california history
killing
102 million trees
so after 2017 flooding california was
declared totally drought free
so it's very yin yang i just love that
yin-yang perspective 2011-2017
hardcore california drought massive
issue
and then this wettest winter in almost
100 years right afterwards super yin
yang
and the san luis reservoir it's
artificial lake fifth largest reservoir
in california
one acre foot equals 326 000 gallons
sometimes they use that as a unit of
measurement
california rain falls mostly from
october through
may more in norcal than in socal
75 percent of total rainfall volume
happens north of sac so north of sac
75 of the total rainfall volume is
happening
so whereas 75
of the total water demand is in socal
and that's because of population and
agriculture so
basically the large volume of rainfall
is happening north of sac but then
the large demand is happening south and
so we have to move it down for
population and agriculture so state
water project's very important
summers are very dry in the state
snowfall on sierras
feeds the network of reservoirs and
surface water sources
low rainfall snowfall can result in
drought
and this is one of those important
points that i was mentioning a little
bit earlier that one large earthquake
will put tens of millions of people in
california without water so
one large earthquake screwing up the
state water project could put
30 million people without water and it
could put
most of the united states without
access to a third of their vegetables
two-thirds of their nuts and two-thirds
of their fruit
so there's also hundreds of millions of
people around
the us and world as well that
have high amounts of demand for
california's lush fruits vegetables and
nuts
so one large earthquake could wreck the
california economy
water supply and global agricultural
industry
we basically have to become gods we we
have to
accelerate our technology accelerate our
spirituality accelerate our
entrepreneurship and accelerate our art
our capabilities as a civilization
basically the robustness the
anti-fragility of
our cell of our organism planet earth
and for us to be able to withstand such
insanities on the richter scale
so that we can robustly maintain our
water supplies our egg systems and
everything
i'll get to more solutions for that
towards the end as well
the california population is currently
40 million but expected to be 50 million
by 2050
so it's only going to be jacking up the
need for water demand significantly
everybody want to visit
it's true california is
top-notch in the united states
top-notch people top-notch culture
top-notch geography
it's amazing top-notch tech top-notch
entertainment
california is approving billions
of dollars in bonds for water
development and management
and this is kind of where i'm giving a
little hint should be focused on
fusion and desalination we'll get to
that
all right so we got a chance to check
this out already those blue
bit blue big big blue dots like you see
there for lake oroville are the
reservoirs
and then you have the aqueducts
as you see there that's kind of rolling
down
into where like san luis reservoir is
the square
yellow squares are the hydroelectric
stations and the triangles are the
pumping stations
and so there you go all of these
different rivers pouring in
from the sierra nevadas into
our water supply
in california and then that being
distributed around
to norcal to the central valley
into socal
san diego is actually doing a good pilot
right now in desalination so we'll
we'll talk more about that later
and then here's another this is kind of
where i also
get a little bit of
excitement for the geographical
information systems
mappers they do such a good job look at
this gorgeous map
of how they mapped
all of these different rivers that lead
into
the sacramento
and then the san joaquin
look at this it's just so beautiful and
so clear
and just look at how fractal it is
that's one of my favorite things
if you if you look at
where the bay area is and if you look
closer to antioch there on the
eastern side of the bay area it's so
beautiful because
right there that's such a beautiful
analog to what the blood vessels
look like inside of the body or what the
neural networks
look like or what the
or how a uh
cellular evolution occurs when it
becomes scaffolded and blossoms into
multi-cells
it's interesting how these grow outs are
so similar in analogs and metaphors
wow i love how well they map that
and then yeah so here's a higher scale
image of what it looks like to see that
california aqueduct the one that's
running
through that middle of the state
and then here's the water supply and
storage in california
so again you got a bunch of these
reservoirs that are measured in acre
feet so you have
shasta and trinity up north you have
oroville
berryessa folsom
malones don pedro
san luis pine flat
mcclure and i mean
i've been i'm so lucky because i've
gotten the opportunity to actually go to
these places
i've been at these places i've
immersed myself in so much of the
california geography so i actually have
a deeper amount of respect for this
entire water system i highly recommend
people especially ones that live here in
california
please take even if it's just the
weekend like take
friday saturday and sunday to just go
somewhere to one of these gorgeous
geographical destinations in california
and just spend the weekend there
just immerse yourself in that nature and
that serenity like john muir and
teddy roosevelt would want you to do who
put the american antiquities act
together in 1906 that
made it so that we actually could
preserve places like
all of our beautiful national parks
across the usa
and that's why california is beautiful
is because of that it was left very
beautiful
and so
there's your key to watersheds you have
the sacramento river watershed san
joaquin river
and tulare lake and then there's the
colorado river there on the right
and this is the most labeled geographic
information systems
that i could find this one's the most
labeled in the most
of the entire state of the rivers
specifically
so so beautiful
and then this is that shasta dam that we
were talking about
above so this is one of the most
northern dams in
california
these are very beautiful structures
they're both
arguably spiritually and scientifically
we'll figure out better ways
right we're gonna desalinate use fusion
for that we have better
and better ways to preserve our natural
environments rather than damming them up
to use the
hydroelectric power and and
to provide us with with the water um
over the time that it's actually not
undergoing the process of
snowfall and then melting and then we
can dam it up so we have better
solutions to this that we're
currently exploring and working on so
that we can actually not have these but
it's it's almost like uh how how can you
say this it's like the
it's almost in a sense it's like the
it's like the model t
right it's like the ford model t and
today we have the tesla
right and you have to respect the model
t
you know what i mean it's not as safe
it's not as efficient it's not as
fast it's not as luxurious uh and
neither were
120 years ago the first airplanes that
the wright brothers made out of
out of out of wood and cloth like
that was dangerous uh and uh
but you have to respect the fact that
you know today we're flying around in
these commercial planes
a hundred thousand of them fly every
single day
commercially across the world and
that we have to respect the
the cloth and wood plane just like we
have to respect the model t
just like we have to respect these this
this california state water project
project that has so many of these dams
and so many of these pumping stations
because it was it was our baby step you
know it was one of our baby steps along
the way to a more
enlightened a more scientific a more
spiritually
seventh generationally
artistically sound and robust strategy
that we're going towards next
all right so now we'll unpack some of
the nuance
of the la water sources
well what more can i say well welcome to
what they
man i can't get rid of that i love it
it's so nice
i love being here in socal all right
so
you get mountainous snowmelt from the
rockies in the eastern sierra nevada
and there's three large aqueducts supply
water over hundreds of miles to the 13
million plus people in the la metro area
two are from the owens river area and
the third is from the colorado river
right so we're going to unpack those
water rights issues with the owens river
and then the colorado river so there's
three of those
total large aqueducts that are supplying
water over hundreds of miles to the 13
plus million people
whereas when we get really good at
fusion and desalination we can have it
right offshore
and there's just good ways to deposit
the concentrated
saline back into the ocean which we'll
describe that's one of the big
environmental concerns
so 60
of the los angeles water system is from
the cra the colorado river
aqueduct and that starts at the
california arizona border
and it travels 242 miles
this is from the rocky mountains
origination point
to over 1 000 miles away and can deliver
up to 1 billion gallons daily
so just to give you guys the visual
that's right here so here you have the
on the left you can see that's the
colorado river that's coming down
and then there's the parker dam where it
stops and then it's shot over hundreds
of miles
uh and pumped a bunch of stations up
and over the san bernardino mountains um
into los angeles to 13
plus million people and so this is a big
sort of issue is that you have these uh
you have like a billion gallons
daily that are being consumed by
people here in los angeles
and that
it's just being pumped you know a
thousand miles
away from its source in the rockies and
so
there's a much more local solution right
and this is
this is something we can also consider
for vertical farms when you think about
you know back in my home in south dakota
you can think about well
what about the what about the vertical
farms to actually make the
you know the tomatoes locally you know
what if we made the food
there and we picked it right off the
vine in south dakota and ate it rather
than picking it off the vine in
california other states and then driving
it
in trucks to the grocery stores in south
dakota and other states so we have to
think about that
sort of farm to table especially like
vertical farm to table mentality and
that local mentality and that might be
what we use for water rather than
transporting it a thousand miles
and we'll get to some examples where the
middle east is doing a lot of its
desalination right now and
on in the future it's going to be even
better
it's already gotten a lot better with
the technology
33 so again 60 was from colorado river
33
is from the la aqueduct which goes from
the eastern sierra nevada mountains
and that's from the owens river and
reservoirs that's 430 million gallons
daily
and between 1909 to 1928
it caused los angeles to grow from 61
square miles to 440 square miles
most people don't know this because a
lot of us are you know fresh to
norcal or fresh to socal but you know
you can imagine that's some insane
population growth over
just about 20 years l.a grows from 61
square miles to 440 square miles that's
crazy and then approximately 10
groundwater
it's kind of interesting that the
colorado river aqueduct cra has been
called one of the seven
engineering wonders of american
engineering which is pretty interesting
and then the colorado river comes from
the rocky mountains
and again it's parker dam on lake havasu
on the california arizona border and
that's here
on the right and
also water source for the cap the
central arizona project
half the electricity it generates powers
the aqueduct to pump to la
so at least there's that the parker dam
at least
generates half the electricity to power
those pumps
to la it employed 30 000 people
up to 10 000 at a time over the eight
year build period during the great
depression
so interesting a 220 million dollar bond
was approved
on september 29th 1931
and work began in january 1933 or near
thousand palms and in 1934 the united
states bureau of reclamation began work
on the parker
dam it's always such so interesting
thinking about the foresight required
and all of the humans that did this
right it's not just turning on the tap
and you know being grateful but also
thinking about the tens of thousands of
people that over
even during the great depression put
together the infrastructures that enable
us today to live in such
abundance for our roots to have the
nutrients that are needed for our seed
to be able to produce the gifts
you're going to hear me just drill that
one that's my
favorite analogy that i've ever
uncovered
so the seed needs the nutrients
in the roots just like the tree does in
order for it to produce fruits
is the same way that the human needs the
basic needs
the roots need the nutrients of love
water food shelter
electricity technology education health
care
the basic needs so that the human
themselves can
also produce creative
fruits and gifts into the world
it's the number one analogy from high
level perception
such a good one
and you can see that i started with that
rather than the
consciousness and metaphysics stuff i
wanted to start
very explain like i'm five for people
and build a relationship and build trust
with them
i'll unpack more in some high level
perception streams as well which are to
come
so the aqueduct is finished in 1935
and water first flowed in the aqueduct
on january 7
1939. wow
so grateful to to anybody out there that
actually had a
like a grandparent that worked on
this project it would be really cool to
hear from you
you know email us simulation series
gmail.com
we'd love to we'd love to hear
from you about that that's super
interesting
on any of these california water system
projects if you had
grandparents family friends that worked
on them would be super interesting
all right so that was la socal los
angeles
and now we're up to norcal san francisco
bay area water sources
all right so
the hetchy regional water system
sierra nevada reservoirs in yosemite
national park
the snow melt runs into the tulum
river and fills hetch hetchy
we'll get into the nuance of this i
promise for all of those that
we're going to get into the nuance of
that 2.7
million plus residential commercial and
industrial customers in
30 sf bay area cities across
four counties san francisco san mateo
santa clara and alameda
sf gets 85 percent
of its water from hetch hetchy
approximately 250 million gallons per
day
the other approximately 15 comes from
runoff in the alameda and peninsula
watersheds
produces about 1.7 billion kilowatt
hours per year
meeting twenty percent of sf's
electricity needs
water is some of the cleanest in the us
from hetch hetchy only
primary filtered and disinfected and
almost
entirely gravity fed remember we were
talking about that when you don't need
pumps it's just
going and being pulled by gravity down
to the final
destination more near sea level
280 miles of pipes
60 plus miles of tunnels 11 reservoirs
five pump stations two water treatment
plants
four bay division pipelines bdplc
and those split at fremont
the macalum aqueduct provides
water to 1.4 million in east bay
and that's from the mokulum river in
sierra nevadas
and that can pull up to 325 million
gallons per day
this is also funny because east bay and
peninsula sf also have a little bit of a
funny
little dance that they play so it was
constructed
due to fear of sf hegemony on water
supply
super interesting east bay is like
nah dog we're not letting sf have a
hegemony on this
we gotta it's kind of interesting
because it's also an analogy potentially
to
humans as well is where you want to you
want to also
as you gain your nutrients for your seed
you want to be self-sufficient
and inter independent and interdependent
at the same time
and that you want to help teach other
people that way as well
so almost no fossil fuel consumption to
move water from mountains to tap
peninsula uses crystal springs and san
andreas
our recording studio when it was in san
mateo was right next to the
crystal springs reservoir so beautiful
the uh the north bay one plus million
people use the north bay aqueduct in the
california
state water project from lake oroville
and some use the russian river
and total bay area population is
approximately 7 million plus residents
and this is the san francisco
in 1846 and it was yerba buena
good herb buena
and that's also for those that don't
know
treasure island which is that island
that
is where the bay bridge connects from
san francisco to oakland
that's actually called yerba buena
island so yerba wayne island slash
treasure island and so that's kind of
how you can still remember that it was
called yerba buena
and it's funny you wonder like why was
it called good herb
and then you think hmm probably because
the emerald triangle in norcal is where
so much of the good herb
of cannabis is your own like
it's funny it's good so in 1846 you can
see like in this picture look at how
virgin
san francisco looked just so crazy
and i don't know exactly where that is
but it kind of looks like it might be by
maybe like the chrissy field area
super interesting
this kind of stuff fascinates me too
because you gotta run back in your mind
like 150 years and think about what life
was like as well
to really draw a more integral worldview
a more holistic
worldview where you can encompass the
100 billion plus people that have lived
and died before us to build the
civilization that we have today
and so here's a visualization of the
hechi
regional water system so over there on
the right you can see the yosemite
national park
and you can see that hetch hetchy
reservoir
and that we'll again we'll get into the
nuance of what happened
with that and that there it goes
down with all the other reservoirs like
lake eleanor lake lloyd
the new down pedro and what happens is
it goes
down down down all the way
to that fremont area where it splits up
into those separate pipes and you have
it
being fed into the bay area
so that gives you a visual of the
hedgehog original water system
and this is a really cool photo because
a lot of people
in the bay know this picture it's uh
you can kind of see some of those hetchy
uh water system pipelines uh from the
peninsula and you can see them
just like that it looks so cool
and then again so here's that idea of
what is going on
in the hetch hetchy water
system where we're getting all of our
water up in norcal
okay so here now we're going to get into
the nuance of hetch hetchy
and if you if you've never heard about
the
nuance of this water war
in california this dilemma in california
really tune into this one because it's
it's a profound one
it's really fascinating okay
hech hetchy
so the san francisco earthquake and fire
in april 1906 3 000 people died
80 percent of the city was destroyed and
there was a clear lack of water to put
out the fire
the seismograph needle 3000 miles away
across the country
captured it 19 minutes later in albany
new york
and the new york times used to cost 1
cent 115 years ago now it's four bucks a
month i'll show you a graphic for that
in a moment but yeah this is the picture
of
the san francisco earthquake and post
fire
in april 1906 so destructive and here's
the new york times
so interesting back on april 19 1906
there's the little right there in the
center you can see that that's where the
seismograph is and then
up in the top right corner you can see
it used to cost one cent
elsewhere two cents it's so funny
oh my gosh yeah i guess 115 years ago
the new york times was a penny and now
it's four bucks a month so
you always wonder like has purchasing
power increased as well
you know because if it's static that's
not good
you want purchasing power to be
increasing so it doesn't it doesn't feel
like you're paying the same amount for
the new york times 115 years ago as
you're paying for it today but that
you're paying less you want it to be
democratized
you want it to cost less you want to
have more purchasing power
look that up economically it's very
important for you to understand
all right so onwards on hedgehechi so
what happened was i mentioned this a
little
bit earlier but basically one of the
most profound things that the united
states has ever done in my opinion is
the
american antiquities act of 1906 and
john muir who founded the sierra club
pioneered it with teddy roosevelt
it was brilliant legislation saving the
usa
most gorgeous national parks from
private resource extraction and
development
it's a good 7th generation principle
thinking
sf desperately was seeking water source
and could have pulled from other sierra
nevada locations
but pushed to fill heche valley
and this was bad seventh generation
principal thinking
excuse me
and i have many photos of hatchet valley
what it looked like
before we filled it and what it looked
like after we filled it and i'll show
you
also about what we can do moving forward
so i have really good photos for that
and this is very important because
hedgehog is a lot like yosemite valley
and everybody knows yosemite valley is
one of the most beautiful places in the
world
the raker act legislation was the push
to dam and fill the hatchet valley to
provide water to san francisco
and john muir vigorously opposed it
and he said this quote one of nature's
rarest
and most precious mountain temples
often compared to yosemite valley and
beauty
i love that quote by john muir one of
nature's rarest and most
precious mountain temples and right away
we were
pushing to damn it and fill it and
it's just you'll see you'll see here in
a moment will's pictures muir said he
did not want to deny
water to millions of people he just
didn't want the newly formed national
parks to fall victim
to public development government
realized they needed an entity to
enforce park
laws and fight against development thus
birthing the national park service nps
so that was very tdt trauma to treasure
super interesting how those descents
into the shadow
can actually spur the fires of fruits
in this case so we got the national park
service due to
more and more people uh having issues
with
the protection of the national parks so
miura's efforts are also noted as the
start of modern environmentalism
all right now where did the name
hechechi come from
indigenous people have lived in hechechi
valley for 6
000 years
it's always important to do that process
of going back and
immersing ourselves in what their lives
were like right when we talk about
people like the veda grishis or the
egyptians or indus valley or
mesopotamians or
the people that have lived in australia
aboriginals or
any of these sort of planetary spiritual
traditions people that have lived a
really long time in the same areas
we have to really do our best to get
behind what it means to
have lived like that back in that day
and how interconnected
and how primal also um things were so
it's not all roses but there's
definitely some important things to sort
of
grab some of those codes and synthesize
them with modern codes into
you know that sorting algorithm chapter
7.
subjecting the valley to controlled
bushfires
preventing forest from taking over the
valley meadows
so in the 1800s the first white visitors
thought it was
from divine intervention not knowing it
was the product of millennia of
management by native americans
and it was the milwaukee native
americans that
said that cooked seeds of a prominent
grass
growing in the valley into a mush
which they called hechachi
so against you think you're like you're
walking in there as first white visitor
and you're like oh my god it's divine
intervention look at how the meadows are
so beautiful but it was really because
of millennia of management by native
americans
super interesting that's documented
and you can be a
a skeptic and and think well that's
potentially just some story that's being
told and it was you know
was actually divine intervention and
they're just trying to get money and all
stuff but
almost certainly it's true that
different indigenous around planet did
things like this
over time to ensure a
a harmonious relationship with their
environment
now it's cool that a cooked seeds of a
prominent
grass growing in the valley into a mush
is called hechechi and that's where the
name comes from
so the raker act is passed in 1913 by
the wilson administration
again this is just seven years after
the american antiquities act of 1906
allowing the only time in our nation's
history for a single city to develop one
of our national parks for its own
inclusive
exclusive use so it's the only time
that our american antiquities act has
been violated to make the
to fill hedgehedge and provide the water
to the bay area
four million people per year go to
yosemite valley
without knowing that 15 miles
north a second gorgeous valley used to
exist
so just 15 miles north of yosemite
is the hedgehog valley that is arguably
equally as beautiful as yosemite
so again think about all of that beauty
that can be
taken in in spite have deep inspiration
happen from that
we'll get into more of that soon so it
was the ashignissi dam
that was finished in 1923 the source of
water and power was on public land so no
private profit could be derived from the
development
and sf has been accused of selling the
hydroelectric power to pg e
who then resells it back to the public
at a profit sf is currently not using
their share of the water in lake don
pedro the biggest reservoir on the tulum
river
so a dam removal would cost somewhere
between 3 to 10
billion us dollars the don pedro
reservoir holds
two times as much water as hechechi only
modest new supplies would be required in
the driest years otherwise everything is
already available for diversion
opportunity of not repeating mistakes
and creating an experience of visiting
hachachi valley that could be superior
even to yosemite
valley because now we have the 2020s
insight and technology and
and uh foresight as we develop it
hechi remains as the greatest
blemish in any of our national parks
damn it's an important statement though
to think about it that way
within two years after draining the
valley grasses
would cover most of its floor within 50
years
vegetative cover would be complete
except for exposed rocky areas
and with intensive management recovering
the original state of the meadow as the
native american
created would be feasible
it's also interesting because only
cutting a hole
through the base is necessary rather
than removing the whole thing
and then i had this profound moment
while i was synthesizing this
note in october of 2020 and it was very
interesting because
i go i wrote like wow i'm really seeing
the future right now
we leave a small chunk of the damn at
the base
the all shaknessi and make a small
historical museum
and so a couple generations down the
line our grandkids will see this big
nature recovery that we made with the
hatchet valley
and be proud globally to have made this
incredible
landmark back and
i wrote remember the future
and this is very profound and very
important you can you can envision
those children coming and learning about
that process
and seeing that last pit of the dam
that's left and immersing themselves in
the
hechachi valley just like the yosemite
valley and
having that drive so much inspiration so
much economic growth so much
prosperity and then doing things like
fusion and desalination
for the water supply uh and in this case
there's also the
the new don pedro dam as well along the
way to that
fusion and desalination future so
raising the new don pedro dam 30 feet
would store the hetch hetchy water
supply
hetch hetchy restoration could result in
recreational value
of up to 180 million dollars per year or
possibly an overall
economic value of up to 100 billion
overall economic value it's huge
and this is interesting this is also
super duper interesting
so it's no surprise to me that i'm so
deeply
passionate about things like this
california water system and that this
idea of hedgehechi
was something that even at the time i
didn't realize but
my friend grace buchlow she was my
close friend during debate and i went to
the winter formal with her as a date too
and i hung out with her and my other
friend luke hawkins
in berkeley in 2012 and this is super
interesting because at that time i was
somewhere around
20 years old right so i'm only 20 years
old at this time
and and she worked at a restore
hedge head she for four months in 2012
while she was in california
so it's crazy because she
was here visiting for four months
working on restore hedge head she and
i'm 20 years old and i have no idea kind
of what she's doing but she's
already at this kind of like next level
of thought
even though it took me eight years
longer it took me until 2020 to come to
the
you know profound realization that she
had made in 2012. so it's interesting
how consciousness realizes these things
at
different times right you can't the good
old quote you can't pull on flowers to
make them grow faster
and i saw her on the plane flying back
from san francisco to denver in january
2020 when i was coming back from my talk
at pcma
and even the hedgehechi website says for
a second yosemite
i even messaged grace and i told her i'm
like
i'm like i'm like you know it became a
big thing for me to want to
uh to drain the hatchet valley and to
go to the new new don pedro dam and then
to fusion and desalination
and so that we could have this and i
messaged her that that
it was so profound that i had can't come
to this realization that she was doing
2018 and she said or she was doing in
2012
and she said she said yeah good to hear
from you
drain the valley so yeah
it's so interesting how you know you got
to see the meaning you have to see
the profundity you have to see the
synchronicity in all of these things in
life
rather than taking it from a nihilistic
perspective
my biggest critique about the hetch
hetchy website
uh for restoring hetchy is that there's
no plan on how to fund and execute the
demolition
there's a little bit on how sf will fill
the void of missing
water a little on long-term restoration
plans
but there's nothing again nothing on
nuclear fusion
as where we should be focused it's very
environmentally driven which is good
but can be a lot clearer with a video
showing all
these details to make the true push
and here's that hedgehechi aqueduct that
you can see here
it's so interesting and then here's
another
visual of the hedgehog reservoir and
aqueduct
and remember if you want to see these
images just take a screenshot
and then upload it into
images.google.com and you can pull them
up yourselves
and more data about them as well
all right so now we're getting into the
territory that
is gonna be very um touching
to to people so um
i'll i'll probably go through a
a short bit about this um
and hopefully hopefully it can it can
inspire you so
this is the photo that was taken of the
hechechi
valley uh before it was dammed up
with the ashagnessi dam so this is an
actual photo i believe it's
somewhere around that 1910ish
timeline or so and so
again just immerse yourself in the
beauty of that like look at how much it
looks like yosemite is so
incredibly gorgeous and it's calling for
humans to be able to go there
and get inspired and play and relax and
absorb the
spiritual and scientific energy
and so then this is a artist's depiction
also of the
hatchet valley serene
the meadows redwoods waterfall
deer
beautiful river another
artist depiction gorgeous
serene tranquil
spiritual love bliss joy
ecstasy looks amazing and then this is
the ashagnessi dam
so this is what we did to it we dammed
it up
and then here's what it looks like now
so this is the modern hedgehechi
reservoir now
and of course the laws are very strict
so there's nobody that's going on it
although there are proposals to try and
allow people to go on it but
you know let's screw some stuff up when
someone you know
drops their can in it you know and
bathes with their sunscreen and stuff
like that so
you know there's another image of the
damned
and there's another image of hedgehechi
damned
and then here's uh one of the nicer
sort of satellite views i like this one
a lot this one was really
nice so this is what it looks like from
the satellite right so you think like
holy cow
like that's you know that's the hatchet
reservoir they're the so
draining that would just open up this
massive
gorgeous valley look at that
look at how cool and playful and fun
that'd be it's so cool and so create
just north of yosemite this one's really
nice too
this one's really beautiful this one
definitely touches my heart
but you guys didn't think there would be
a sales pitch
for draining hedgehog in the middle of
the
california water system breakdown
so
now you know now you know yeah here's
another one this one's really nice
because it's
literally the the artist right in front
of
the the damned so the undammed picture
right in front of the damned
wow yep and then
here's a beautiful picture of somebody
also in that
valley
i believe that's on the other aspect of
it the other side of it
alright so
in general the california water wars are
absolutely crazy
so it's super controversial water rights
debates whoever brings the water brings
the people
right as we've been talking about so sf
you have hetch hetchy
it's the national park versus drinking
water for millions right so we want to
open that up but then there's millions
of people that rely on it and
with the la with the owens river you
have farmers
versus metro so since 1913 diversion to
los angeles caused
the ruining of the valley's economy and
drying of the owens lake
and so lawsuits forced lawdp
led wp to start releasing water
into the 62 mile long
lower owens river in december 2006
and in less than one year the lower
owens river was
teeming with fish birds and other
wildlife
so this is the type of stuff that you
can see you see like something that's
really dried up
not prospering at all because the water
has been diverted to where more people
are at
and then if you do get the opportunity
to just
pour the water in in just one year
back to teeming with fish birds and
wildlife
so it's kind of like an urban versus
rural debate so
you know you got one you have increased
the redistribution of water to large
agricultural and urban sectors
or two you have increased conservation
and preserve the natural ecosystems and
communities of the water sources
so this is kind of the the draw is that
you have san francisco the bay area you
have los angeles you have socal you have
these massive metros that want to
redistribute the water there
but then you have the local uh
communities and natural ecosystems that
want to preserve it
so this is what it looks like so by the
way for those that don't know this is
what's going on
on the on the east side of the state of
california so there's mono lake
right there you can see that's the
nevada border as well and so that's the
owens river and the valley
and how it got diverted down with that
los angeles aqueduct there at the bottom
and if you ever drive through that area
you'll see
that it's not as thriving as it
could be because of this but then again
los angeles and
everything that it achieved um given the
fact that it got water
that's also difficult to calculate
because that's been a lot of creativity
and a lot of entertainment and a lot of
other things that have been brought to
our world from that
and so here's your again your
geographical
information systems map of that similar
vision all right
all right so now we are reaching the end
so this is kind of one of my big
solutions
because it's not only the 30 million
people
in the california that are depending on
water and it's not only the the
central valley that's producing this
massive amount of agriculture for
not only the 330 million people in the
u.s a third of the vegetables and
two-thirds of the fruits and two-thirds
of their nuts but california is
exporting
so much of their agricultural production
around the planet
and then you know furthermore is fusion
desalination
and reclamation there's you know they're
sdg number six for a reason because
you know if you look at somewhere like
lagos in nigeria
you have a very similar issue where
there's 10 million plus people
that need access to that sdg number six
clean water sanitation
but they can't get access to that basic
need in a systematized way that enables
them to
meet that basic need so that they can be
creative and lagos isn't the only
place there are plenty of other
especially coastal cities around the
planet
where we could have significantly better
um processes that enable
uh the instantaneity of having
water on tap and that enabling that
primal need to to sort of dissipate and
hedonically re-baseline to higher levels
to be able to achieve
goals so fusion
desalination reclamation so point number
one
help pioneer fusion
help pioneer future global technology
and in this case
you really have to take fusion seriously
it's been talked about for a long time
if you don't understand fusion you
should absolutely look up fusion this is
not
fission so become familiar with the
difference between fission and fusion
in in infusion you are actually
fusing atoms and what you're able to
achieve by doing so
is you're able to you're able to extract
more energy that happens from the fusion
then you expended on the process of
fusing them
and that's completely different than
fusion fusion is where the
horrible catastrophes have happened in
the past and this is why fusion is
being invested into by the entire planet
and there's really good reactors like
tocomox a good one but even better it
looks like the stellarator format is an
even better upgraded version
and we're like basically babies playing
in the fusion space there are going to
be
star trek ways to to win in the fusion
space
and so we have to think like the star
trek future that we want
and then architect the fusion
technologies that get us there as a
planet with the top scientists the top
engineers
the top economists the top geopolitical
strategy to ensure that that actually
occurs
and so by doing this by really focusing
on future we can
really crush our planetary uh
like to crush the sdgs we have the want
we want
no poverty we want zero hunger we want
the quality education we want clean and
affordable electricity we want
clean water and sanitation we want all
these basic needs and fusion enables
that process as well
so fusion in a sense is one of the most
massive
panaceas for many of the world problems
and we need to become more awake
to that fact
so restore hetch hetchy that gives us
approximately 100 billion plus dollars
in economic value
a natural sanctuary global birthright
we want to restore the owens valley
community economy and wildlife who has
suffered for a hundred years
right so hedgehechi restorationist
norcal and then
owens valley restoration is socal and so
these are very important
water rights disputes that we want to
heal we want to heal we want to
integrate
we want to move on
so we want to be drought resilient we
talked about being anti-fragile we
talked about being robust
for earthquakes for droughts for all of
these things for human and egg water
consumption
ensuring that california's 400 plus
agricultural commodities can provide for
the usa and the world
frictionlessly
we want to remove all of the water
diversion projects so that's dams
pipelines
pump stations reservoirs restore
completely to original nature
and that fusion provides way more energy
than hydroelectric
so it's not even an argument we don't
even need the hydroelectric power
we don't need the wind power we don't
even need the solar power
that's what's brilliant you know you
always think you look at the videos of
you know star trek and you look at the
videos of even just like futurism topics
where there's the
veto the vertical takeoff and landing
right
those massive like quadcopters that
transport humans and they're very
futuristic what do they run on
nuclear fusion they figure out
in the most technologically pinnacle way
possible
to fuse the atoms and to gain that and
harness that energy
again you have to remember that we're
like we're crickets trying to imagine
the big game
and so it's important to remember that
chuck the hubris to the side and
remember
to be humble that
think like a hundred years ago the
wright brothers
putting together what they were doing to
think that there would be a hundred
thousand commercial flights happening
every day right so it's the same thing
with us today doing the baby tinkering
with fusion
in 100 years it's everywhere
and this is interesting 2.6 is restore
colorado river to its original state
and it's because the colorado river is
being overdrawn as well
so that also deserves its love and this
steps closer to the star trek future of
abundance
no scarcity meeting all basic needs all
gifts being actualized
and then fusion is also very important
for wastewater reclamation efficiencies
and we'll actually do another
conversation on reclamation
with our note synthesis
and distillations here on these streams
you'll get a taste of that because the
reclamation process is very important
you can't just think like oh i'm going
to open up the tap and then i'm going to
wash my dishes or my
my shower my hair or flush my toilet
with poop in it
and then i'm just going to not care
about what happens no like it all
goes through a massive network of pipes
into
the water reclamation plant and they
have to treat everything properly they
have to remove basically 90
plus percent you want to be really in
like 98 99 plus percent
of all the contaminants and we'll get
into some of the nuance here before you
actually
deploy back into the hydrological cycle
so we have these massive goals like
these are these these are
massive goals we we need to be thinking
more like this
star trek future with these goals
we can do this guys we can do this i
love you all
we can do this we can do this remember
the future
so we're going to bump up epa standards
globally to 100
contaminant removal including
pharmaceuticals and i'll explain why
that's important here in a moment as
well
uh pharmaceuticals are uh there
environmental pollutants you can get
like parts per trillion
of the pharmaceuticals over time that
are
exiting our urine and then going into
the hydrological cycle and nothing's
ever
taking them out so we're constantly
drinking parts per trillion of
pharmaceuticals that are only building
up as more and more people take them
so stop downstream pollution for the
hydrological cycle
every major coastal city will begin
using this infrastructure using fusion
to desalinate billions of gallons of
seawater into fresh water daily that
tastes even better than spring water
and is even healthier fused with more
nourishment we don't know of yet
this part we have to imagine
with the walt disney we have the pixar
we have to imagine you know
how can we fuse more nourishment into
water that we don't even get in the
hydrological cycle so the same way that
a pharmaceutical is actually a pollutant
of the water of the hydrological cycle
how can we fuse things
into the water supply into the
hydrological cycle that
actually we haven't heard of yet and you
can think about this kind of like in
biotech has we
enabled gfp and channel redopsin
and
crispr cas9 and all these different
biotic advancements that we found from
from the biodiversity of the planet we
can potentially
add some of that also into our
augmentations
and you have to think about this on a
planetary level because there's so many
cities that
that are coastal that desperately need
this i've been i've been looking into
them in their water architectures
nyc dubai london mumbai shanghai tokyo
lagos
sao paulo singapore
so saudi arabia is currently pioneering
fusion
saudi arabia's saline water conversion
corporation swcc provides 50
of municipal water in the kingdom they
are the largest desalinating seawater
corporation in the world
responsible for 20 of worldwide
desalinated water
it's the second largest electrical
provider in the country
they operate 32 plants in saudi arabia 4
000 kilometers of pipelines 10
000 plus employees assets valued at 20
billion plus dollars contracted to build
new desalination plant in japan and
south korea
so again this is one of those things
where you want to do a little bit of
mimesis
right you want to go and look at what
saudi arabia has done
and you want to just like kind of what's
happened with the united states is
ip you know planetary wise people have
wanted to come
and take some of the ip here and do some
mimesis around the world in their
countries
very similar the us and other developed
countries can look at what saudi is
doing right now
and take some of that mimesis you use
some mimesis to take some of their
strategy and architectures
and augment them to the next level add
our own creativities
and whatnot san diego in the us has been
doing a pretty good job at this so san
diego water sources
this is crazy san diego purchases 80 to
90 percent of its water mostly from the
norcal california
state water project swp 30 in the
colorado river 50
10 local water supplies and conservation
and then there's the the cloud bud lewis
carlsbad desalination plant and that was
approved by san diego water authority
and that's now responsible for providing
approximately eight percent of san diego
county's water in 2020
the facility cost one billion dollars to
build
including the plant the pipelines and
upgrades
to existing facilities to use the water
it's the
largest desalination facility in the
western
hemisphere
this is really the kind of stuff that
we have to get very excited about like
the largest desalination facility in the
western hemisphere is literally located
in san diego
in california like that's awesome we
need to be pumped about that
and again we need to do some mimesis
like what is the carlsbad desalination
plant doing
and how are they providing eight percent
of san diego county's water right now
and how can we do some mises in order to
be able to take that onto los
angeles san francisco you know that kind
of thing
and beyond to around the world so they
produce up to 50 million gallons of
water a day
enough for 400 000 people
and so just to give you an idea my
hometown of sioux falls south dakota
uses
excuse me uses somewhere around 15 or so
million gallons of water
a day so
this is very cool that you know that
basically san diego
is providing like three sioux falls
cities worth of of water
with desalination that's so interesting
a negative is byproduct of concentrated
brine
increasing salinity of water offshore
and i'll explain it here in a moment
the nation's largest most
technologically advanced and energy
efficient seawater desalination plant
awesome and i'll get into
a little bit more on desalination in its
own
stream conversation and
i'll explain kind of what perth is doing
a little bit right now
to give you a taste of what's going to
happen in that one but
the way you counter the negative
byproduct of the concentrated brine
because the idea is when you extract out
all of the saline
all that brine what happens is it gets
really concentrated
and then you have your fresh water over
here and then what you do with that is
you just put it back in the ocean but
you can't just put it back in the ocean
over and over again in the same spot
because you're going to cause the marine
life disruption in that area
so what you need to do is you need to
take it and what perth has been doing is
they've been taking it a little bit
uh in a in a slightly more distributed
fashion and that's been helpful
but i would go uh beyond perth australia
and what i would do is i would go to the
next step which is you take the brine
and you you know you package it up onto
barges
and then you take those barges and you
take the barges out to the sea and then
you drop
really small amounts of brine every
while and then eventually you have
drones that go out and just drop the
brine
out there or maybe in the future there's
a way to use fusion in order to be able
to
figure out a way to take care of the
brine right again it's ridiculous how
plentiful our our planet's
sea water is something 97
of of the planet is the sea water and so
we must be able to desalinate it with
fusion
so costs more than reservoir water but
less than importing water
so it costs more than reservoir water
for desalination
right now plant requires approximately
40 megawatts to operate
and is that mega what's it millions
i think right and cost of approximately
50 million dollars per year project
commenced in 1993 after five years of
drought
exactly so after five years of drought
there was a big
trigger in order for them to be able to
make this
general atomics pioneered the membrane
technology they are an energy and
defense corporation la jolla with 15 000
employees
doing research in fission fusion
surveillance aircraft drones electronic
wireless and laser technologies
and then i made this statement here
because it's very important but i'll
actually get back to it in a second
because i want to i want to show you
this picture
um here at the top you can see that's
the mouth of the lagoon
and then you have the intake and then
what's going on is there's your power
plant and then next to it's the
desalination plant
and then you have the desalination
happen and you have the outfall right
and so this is also what the interior
looks like
with the one in san diego
and so all of those is where the insane
process of extracting out all of the
what you don't want in the
seawater is happening
and then i'll just quickly uh explain
this what i wrote here
that if wikipedia makes
an algorithmic script that goes through
each page and clicks on each reference
source at the bottom and then sends a
human to each page that returns back a
four or four
404 error broken link description so
that the sourcing can be fixed because
occasionally on wikipedia i run into
this issue where i go to the bottom
to where the references and sources are
and i click on them and then i get a
four or four
error broken link description but
wikipedia themselves can write
i mean i support them i pay them monthly
and i recommend actually everybody to
pay wikipedia monthly
because they're everyone uses it and
it's a very important uh decentralized
i i don't know if everybody probably
it's probably approaching
4 billion people use wikipedia i
wouldn't be surprised if half of the
planets using wikipedia
and so everybody should at least be
contributing as much as they can
and so even like a dollar or five
dollars or ten dollars a month
is very important to be able to for
wikipedia to do things like this
and so we can become even better at
decentralized
processes like the encyclopedia okay so
now i'll talk a bit about the
pharmaceuticals and the water supply
so what i was saying earlier is that you
have these environmental persistent
pharmaceutical
pollutants they're called eppps in the
strategic approach
to international chemicals management
essay icm
the international society of doctors for
the environment isde
and environmental impact of ppcp
pharmaceuticals and personal care
products
and so what's going on is that
pharmaceutical residues are
contaminating water and soil
around our planet and many other global
micro pollutants that avoid our
filtration
pharmaceuticals have been entering our
hydrological cycle over the last 50
years in mass
and they act on all living cells when
they are recycled through our bodies
although the parts petroleum
concentration is very low
so eppps are already found in water all
over the
world it's been tested could be
extincting species
and balancing sensitive ecosystems
already affecting reproductive systems
of frogs
fish and mussels genetic developmental
immune and hormonal health effects like
estrogen chemicals
eppp bioaccumulation and toxicity is a
top world building health risk in our
water supply
let's read that one more time because
now you know what epps are eppp
bioaccumulation and toxicity is a top
world building health risk in our water
supply all water on earth is part of the
same stable pool
as larger amounts of pharmaceuticals are
consumed their concentrations in
drinking water will increase
so one they pass through our urine into
the environment via sewage treatment
plants
unused pharmaceuticals are dumped down
toilets are thrown into landfills
manufacturing plants unintentionally
release pharmaceuticals into the
environment
hospital waste water discharge plays a
major role
and when treated sewage sludge gets
reused as fertilizer on farms
soya absorbs the antibiotics and has
been found in their leaves
they're literally finding antibiotics in
the leaves of soil
pharmaceutical testing of german surface
waters 27 different pharmaceutical
substances and concentrations of more
than 0.1 microgram per liter
up to 150 substances have been detected
in total
150 different pharmaceutical substances
some of these environmental
pharmaceutical chemicals are well known
to have serious genotoxic effects in
humans
half-life in nature varies depending on
the environment air water soil sludge
but is more than one year for several
compounds
see there are 3 000 plus pharmaceutical
substances are approved in the
european union today so
in a small study several pharmaceuticals
were found in the milk of goats
cows and humans there you go epps now
you know
so they're very important we need
entrepreneurs to solve this problem we
need artists
we need creative people to really tackle
these biggest problems on our planet
and we need the proper incentive
structures that give them
encodes of law that enable them to do so
all right and i'm just going to wrap on
the climate co2
in parts per million sea levels this is
extremely important as we're of course
talking about
the water system planetary waters in
california's water system agriculture
all that kind of stuff so
in 25 years our sea levels have risen 80
millimeters which is approximately 3.14
inches
which again no surprise it's not an
accident it's not even a synchronicity
it's just beauty
it's literally beauty that 80
millimeters is 3.14
inches which is literally pi so
again just really just realize these
synchronicities right
i don't know if you guys know this yet i
haven't really talked about it publicly
because i only discovered it during the
distillation of high level perception
but
3.14 is pi and it's also
exodus 3 14 right
in exodus in the old testament is the
i am that i am or i am god i
am right so when
you're getting the moses and the burning
bush and you're getting the
the the question of tatavam asi you are
that
we are that or the jude we
the unity of all being the unity of all
existence uh you know you are god we are
god
we are the publishers and the players of
the game
we are the ones that came from the
metaverse and we're going to the
metaverse in the cyclic cosmology
okay anyway that's a little bit of
consciousness metaphysics stuff that i
talk about in high level perception but
remember that these things are not
accidents they're purposely
the beauties they're the beauties treat
them that way
and so in those 25 years our sea levels
rose 80 millimeters 3.14 inches that's
nasa
and projections are 54 inches of rise by
2100
if emissions continue at current rates
in 100 years
temperatures have risen one degree
celsius which is approximately 1.8
degrees fahrenheit
that's again nasa emissions grow by 0.6
percent
each decade that's pretty intense
from 20 000 years ago to 1850 co2 parts
per million went up from 185 to 280
and that's the noaa the national oceanic
and atmospheric administration
and then from 1850 to 2020
co2 ppm went up from 280 to 415 so in
just 170 years the co2 ppm went
up 135 which is crazy and then
just in the last 15 years
the co2 ppm went up 35
ppm in 15 years so crazy
and so here's your chart from nasa
and this is in the sea height variation
in millimeters so that's where it goes
up to 80.
so 3.14 inches raised
in c height and then you have the
temperature anomaly here from 1880 all
the way up until
going up a degree celsius up until 2020
1.8 degrees fahrenheit
extremely important
and then this is the co2 and ppm and
parts per million of just the last 15
years going from 380 to 415.
it's so nuts guys we got to tackle this
so again it's really important to be
very very careful with our data and with
our sources
and be doing multiple multiple
tests of these hypotheses and to have
global
dialectics happening at the world level
stages where we can actually get the
right
you know we can get the right data
interoperability and data fusion and
leverage artificial intelligence to come
up with these
most ideal visualizations of the
planetary data so we as humans can know
our effect on the planet the
anthropocene
so we have to be very careful because
it's literally
our water supply it's literally our food
supply it's literally our suffering and
our well-being
that's at stake right so we have to be
smart about this
we need to incentivize entrepreneurship
incentivize creativity
incentivize spiritual awakening we have
to incentivize these things
all right so that was awesome we covered
you know you guys learned about
epps environmental persistent
pharmaceutical pollutants
that's great you guys learned about the
importance of fusion and desalination
i'm glad that that hopefully really
landed
um san diego as a pioneer here in
california eight percent
currently is they're responsible for you
guys learned about saudi arabia
pioneering fusion
on the planetary level you learned about
all of these incredible benefits of
fusion
and what they can do for us we have to
do these things guys
there's no we have to get to that star
trek future of abundance
you know we talked about some of the
california water wars with
hetch hetchy as well as the owens river
you know here's our our this is our
beautiful hedgehechi that we want to
be able to immerse ourselves in in a
couple of decades let's get there guys
let's get there let's get there
here's currently what the hechachi
aqueduct looks like
john muir the greatest blemish in any of
our
national parks boom
so interesting indigenous people lived
there and maintained it controlling bush
fires in order to preserve those valley
meadows
one of nature's rarest and most precious
mountain temples
again if you haven't looked up the
american antiquities act of 1906
john muir and teddy roosevelt highly
recommend looking that up
that's one of the most important aspects
to where
laissez laissez-faire sort of uh
allowing
you know uh markets and capitalism
uh to to go is vast majority of what
we should do is ethically morally
spiritually evolve and then
allow ourselves to sort of create and
let markets go
but then there's that slight bit of
intervention that has to happen which is
the 1906
american antiquities act or the perverse
incentives what happened with
purdue pharma and the opioid epidemic
right so there are these small
interventions that have to happen
um in order to prevent uh perverse
incentives from
from killing humans with opioid
addiction or in this case destroying our
national parks
so you guys learned about the bay
area water sources you guys learned
about the
los angeles water sources
and we got into depths
of the actual california state
water project
we got into the depths about the beauty
of aqueducts
and how genius they are
and these key takeaways guys these
highlights
you got to remember them you know you
got to remember them
you know so many of our viewers are in
the united states you gotta remember
like every time you go to a grocery
store a third of all the vegetables came
from california
two thirds of all the nuts and fruits
came from california you do
not want california to have any water
problems
because you want to make sure that you
have your food in your grocery stores
and the same thing's true with the 30
million people here that rely
on water that we can't risk
the horrendous multi-year droughts
there are many things we need to become
more anti-fragile we need to become more
robust we need to become more star trek
we need to become more resilient we need
to truly embody and incentivize these
principles economically
entrepreneurially creatively
artistically spiritually geopolitically
we must do that that's a must
remember california itself as a state is
the sixth largest economy in the world
as a state it's crazy silicon valley
hollywood los angeles san diego and
central valley
it's crazy it's beautiful agriculture
wow
all right guys boom there you go
so that was our first
breakdown of my polymothy
so you guys know i'm a polymath you guys
know that
i have done a lot of this style of work
with distilling
synthesizing and distilling down the
complex concepts into
these sort of super relatable super
narrative
driven super storytelling super visual
and super
exegesis right
excuse me with the coloration the
formattings
the emojis you know the images the
narrative all these things
excuse me together
and so
you'll see a lot more of this in the
future you'll i just want to also say
you'll see this compressed even more i
know this one took a little while
you know this one's approaching its
second hour
and i want to say that it was important
for me to go through the process
of taking the longer chunk of time to do
this
so that now in the future i know how to
move a little bit quicker
and also so that i know that even
further in the future
we're gonna be building the the
animation teams and the storytelling
teams
that can that can kind of pixar and walt
disney this
this you know this two-hour explanation
of this note of the california water
system
and that we can really compress it down
into just a couple minute
animated video that's the future
that's our future we're becoming mimetic
gods
and so these are the types of things
that we're working on doing
so over time i'm just gonna keep
compressing and keep distilling and keep
getting you as much of the most abstract
juicy artistic essences of these
profound points
and disseminating those across the
planet and awakening people and
enlightening them more to things like
this
so thank you very much for tuning in i
greatly appreciate you
i would love to hear your thoughts in
the comments below
let me know what you think about this
style of
presentation this polymathic style of
showcasing what's
i've distilled in my notes also
let me know what you think about the
topic of california water system would
love to hear from you about that
share this content with other people
that drastically need to know
about what's going on in these complex
water systems
i'm going to give you some more
notes specifically on water systems like
the new york city water system
and desalination in general and
the process of water reclamation as well
and also other places around the world
and how they source their water so
it's a very very important thing i mean
again water is no joke it's
super duper important and for basic
needs and also for actualizing gifts and
also for agriculture i mean it's crazy
how important it is so
i love you guys love you all super
grateful for you
and uh yeah share it as you guys know
you already know
do that subscribe follow us all our
links are below support us if you'd like
we would love your your help with
building the future with all of our big
visionary goals so you can find our
links below to support us as well
help us grow and support the other
artists entrepreneurs the spiritual
leaders
in your communities scientists that you
believe in support them help them
flourish
actualize your own gifts focus on that
and focus on architecting the social
fabric
that maximizes
gift as well
so that's it everyone
go and build the future manifest your
dreams into the world we love you very
much
thank you for tuning in hope to spot you
lots of
value much love
and also investigate consciousness
the nature of reality
you